EMOTIOPAHAPPEN.
KEYWORD, PA.
OTHER NEWSFOLLOWING
RIGHT NOW, PARTS OF  FINLONE SAA
NIA RI STEPHAN? EEG OF M
OUT HERE AND
ARE OUT TRYING TO CLEAN IT UP
HERE.
. AT I CAN TELL YOU,E  NTERSTAT
YOU TO GET O FREEWAY G ANDHA WH
THERE READY FOR ALL  AROSS SOUT
THERN CALIFORNIA FACING ECEDENTU
FLOODS, DAMAGING GROWTH IN
BEARINTH
RI A WATER
TAKING OVETHE
CATHL  O
OUND. PABLE FOR ANYONE N
>> WE ARE TELLG PEOPLE TT N'HAIR
ONE, ROARE
RE IS STILL
TETE OVER THE ROADS D HOW SAFE
INTO THE MORNING R
DRIVERUCLO
NS FREEZING
>> CARS FLOATING ANDAD
AUTTIWARNINHEDS OF RE
TH GET ACROSS. YYOU DON'T
>> THE AREA SAW WORTH
>> THEN JUST 24
ROOF>> DLIOVS
S EXPE
RECORDMOREN ES WAS TESTED BUT RO
>> THE LOS ANGELES F
DEPARTMENT FIELDED MORE THAN 40C
INCIDENTS.
LOS ANGELES PUBLIC SCHOOLSL ON T
AFTECAE  SHUT DOWN THE SCHOOLS
>> THE LOSNGELES ANGCINNATI REDS
WEDNESDAY, POSTPONING THEIR
MANHOLE TODAY.HOUGHTS
SU EVER 0
GETTING  TIMESIR AVERAGE
SUMMER IN  JUST
NUP EFFO, RITY AFTER RAIN WITH
HILARY CTITOOV
BACK OUT HERE INHEDRALU HAVE TO
S, EVETER THE
G
THE I CAN TO AND THAT
IS WHAT IS ENCASEDESE CO